it's just unrealistic to have your hand
in front and try to shoot under it
you might shoot your arm off hi i'm
nicole franks i am the woman's world
fast draw
champion i'm from langley british
columbia canada
i also have 50 world records
12 world championships and over 50
major championship wins and today i'll
be rating fast draw clips for movies
[Music]
in this scene there's a lot of staring
going on and
actually i do this i go to my target and
i just stir it up and i go
when you squint your eyes you typically
are locking in
on your target and you're just trying to
take out any peripheral vision
in your shooting a blink of an eye
is actually .26
roughly and that is my fastest world
record so when they say
blink of an eye there's a reason to that
clint eastwood um doesn't have a lot of
body
movement he's very straight up and down
but you can tell that he actually has
shot before because his wrists are very
firm so when he grabs the gun he just
grabs the gun and he just sort of locks
it right in
and he does shoot out a little bit more
than i would shoot
um but he does have just just a complete
arm movement
it's just super smooth there's actually
a lot of
cutout in his hoster so two different
style of hosters back in the day
some post the leather would go all the
way up to the top
this would make it a lot harder because
you'd have to pull out
a lot further to clear the leather
where he has the leather almost all cut
out for him
that gives you a lot more room to
already start rotating the gun back
quicker and get it out in this scene
you'll see angel
eyes has his hoster position more so to
the left of his body
the reason why people would have this is
most
the time it's um horseback riders they
would keep it on the left-hand side
and they would hold the reins with the
other and then anytime an intruder or
something happens they have the option
of grabbing their gun and shooting
when you have it over to the side of the
hip the gun can actually fall out of the
hoster
a lot more it was just straight it was
just firm and it was a lock draw
so i would give him about an eight
there's nothing pizzazz about it though
in this scene jamie foxx starts off with
his hand
off it's uh the old west style they
would intimidate and move their fingers
to
make people think they were going to
draw ahead of time well some
people believe that hands off is slower
than hands on
i personally don't believe that if i
have hands off a little bit more of a
kick
then if i'm just going and grabbing the
gun
it's a little bit more of a versus just
like
a wrist flick it's just personal
preference he actually has his hoster a
little bit far
back and he's pulling it out so far back
that he sort of stumbles
this little bit in order to get his gun
to go forward
and shoot if he had his gun where i have
it more forward it would come out a lot
easier
jamie foxx was thumbing you can't just
pull the trigger
and fire so you're thumbing the gun by
pulling the hammer back
then you pull the trigger and that fires
it
he was bringing the gun very up and down
and then
really far out which would be good for
accuracy and he is doing point shooting
so it works for this scene
in the second clip jamie foxx is
actually fanning
so he is grabbing the gun and he's using
his
opposite hand and he's fanning the gun
which actually is much quicker
because you can hold down the trigger
and use your posing hand
to fan the gun and that would make it
quicker
versus thumbing each one back
individually one two
one two one two he is doing it right but
the gun is obviously quite heavy for him
because he's aiming downwards see that
little bit of
weak wrist snap he's not shooting
level he's shooting down that might be
because
he can get down on the hammer easier
versus
going straight across so the gun that
jamie foxx is using is a thumbing gun
when it's a thumbing gun the hammer is
back further
so you actually have to come down on the
gun if he had a fanning gun with the
hammer forward it'd be a lot easier to
fan you could actually go straight
across
so i typically use this part of my
finger which is my
middle finger and come down instead of
jamie foxx
using his whole hand you can get your
soft tissues get caught
pinch in the gun versus if you just have
one clean sweep
with my one finger here it can go back
a lot easier i mean the last shot was
bomb he did it in the old
western style but the way he was doing
it was pretty
pretty decent i would definitely give
him like at least a seven out of ten
well she got me huh
so tom cruise is obviously not using a
revolver but his stance is actually very
similar to what i would be doing in fast
draw
um his legs are over shoulder-width
apart
he has his right foot forward and bent
and when he shoots he's actually
bringing his arm back
and pinched in which is very similar to
me i
had his arm out he grabs he comes in and
he shoots and then he does the typical
um nine mil i guess style of shooting
out forward
for his second opponent he does have his
hips thrusted forward
he actually bringing it into his side
and locking the gun
so it's actually a very smooth draw it's
a little bit even more similar to my
style than even those old western clips
like when i'm shooting i have my one
foot more forward
and then he he goes you know like this
where the old school they're like
straight up and down and they're like
you can tell that tom cruise actually
shoots i personally think it was a great
shot i would actually probably give him
a perfect 10 out of 10.
[Music]
it looks as if he may already have the
gun clocked back
and then when he goes to shoot he fires
the gun
and then pretends to fan so it's
actually quite bad
it's so quick that most people would
never notice he also looks a little bit
sloppy when he's doing it he's sort of
like
hunched forward like this and the gun
is like tipped up in the air um
so it wasn't the smoothest draw by any
means
so there's a huge ninth day difference
between
the first clip of westworld and then jim
marsden
actually practicing
he is very straight up and down still
but the third shot in that practice
sequence was
really impressive because he thumbs the
first one and then he fans the second
one he went from being awkward to more
confident with a very clean
stance and clean draw the season one
westworld i
probably would give that more like a
four out of ten um
it was just sloppy there wasn't a lot of
form
on the plus side his training video i
would almost give
a 9.5 out of 10. it was crisp
clean and a lot of improvement
so in this scene as you can see um the
mandalorian is really ready to shoot
he's sort of hovering over his gun he's
just waiting for the guy to get up
and as soon as the guy moves he grabs
his gun
and he just has like a forward motion
for his shot
it's quite high the draw itself was
actually quite smooth
i just really liked that the scene
showed that he was and like
waiting in anticipation for his opponent
for him shooting with such a long gun
and he does have a pretty good
action swift it's going out forward he
locks it
in it's not easy to shoot a long gun
because it's a lot more
pull and to bring it out the draw was
actually pretty good for that style of
gun and
this style of shooting uh nine
if you compare this to collateral um
keanu reeves is actually grabbing with
two hands we're almost pretty much right
off the bat
where um so that's the typical shooting
of a semi-automatic
so the way that um keanu reeves does it
is he's shooting off his
main foot the reason why is you you can
typically get more movement
than when you're um straight you can't
really move as much
but there is different styles of
shooting it's lead foot
opposing foot or width is typically
common
um i just like that he's going with his
lead foot
i just think that it makes it easier for
him to pivot and turn
and it just it looks really clean the
way he's doing it
his front forward is a pivot so he's
shooting and pivoting around
um versus having to turn like his whole
body and moving both feet left and right
left and right
he can just use it as a pivot point it
looks really good i could give him
in my an 8.
clint eastwood is doing a fanning style
he's grabbing the gun and he's locking
it and
he all he has to do is turn his body
it's always going to be level because he
has it
locked into his side so he goes bang
bang
bang tilts his body up
his body down bang the reason why you do
this is just
more accuracy less flimsy wrist less
poking it all around when i'm fanning i
actually thrust my hips
forward which gives me more of an angle
of my
shooting i have my shoulder out and it's
more just a
a pop and lock pop and lock
i do like that he locks it in to get his
opposing
um targets versus using a sloppy wrist
or
moving his whole entire arm so i i do
like that form that is this form that i
use
so a good nine out of ten
[Music]
this is like the definition of point and
shoot
there's my target there i go people
first start shooting they actually do
this and i'm like
oh boy like he's he's punching at his
target he's going as far as he can he's
like bang i got you
so it's basically just a beginner thing
to do when you jump
forward and shoot you have an attendee a
tendency to go low
because you're you know you're you're
almost going forward
um it's just a natural reaction it's not
something that i
ever encourage people to do because it
creates bad habits
um the more you push forward the harder
it will be to draw back
because once you get into habit of doing
something it's super hard to break
he might be sort of turning to the side
um
to get away from shots sometimes people
will shoot
to the side to make themselves um
slimmer
because the more width you are the more
target for somebody shooting back at you
and if you turn to the side you're a
little bit harder to shoot
but he's not shooting back so i don't
really know how he's shooting to the
side
as a quick draw artist i would give this
a tacky two
it was all ugly that was the pin that
we're talking about the firing pin
see how his fingers almost touching it a
lot of people are
don't like those guns for the fact that
you could catch it
but for fanning you wouldn't want to use
one with a pin firing pin
exposed because you could actually poke
your finger with it
the actual thumbing itself the way he
grabbed
the hammer back and thumb the gun looked
really
really good but then all of a sudden
it's like a split clip
and then you see him sort of like jolt
up and try
and messy they trying to shoot under his
arm it's just
unrealistic especially if you're
thumbing the gun to have your hand in
front and try to shoot under it
you might shoot your arm off
uh i didn't like it i thought it was
like really messy
unsafe um i feel like he could have done
a lot better um i would say he probably
gonna get like a three
[Music]
he's definitely throwing him off with
his left hand you watch the hand that
moves first so
he has a good tactic on that one it
comes out of the hoster fairly smoothly
but that's the reason why it's coming
out of the hostel really smoothly is
because it's a lowered hoster
one of the reasons why his hoster might
be lower is give some more
options to move around but his draw has
no like accuracy form so good thing the
guy is only like a foot away from him
he is doing an all arm motion there's no
lock at all to it
and when he does that if you notice he
butts
down his wrist and he actually has his
gun sort of tilted
upwards so he when he goes to draw
he goes all arm and he butts it down
so with all string sports it's actually
very important to have strong wrist
i have incredibly strong wrists so no
matter how i fan
that that my my wrist is always locked
and firm
i'd probably rate it a 5 out of 10. it
doesn't come out badly he's not doing a
lot badly
it's just that he doesn't have a lot of
accuracy
um it it isn't the worst it isn't the
best it's just
mediocre it is the safest gun sport in
the world
um because we're shooting wax or black
powder blanks that's why we can shoot as
fast as we can